haga vous êtes contre vous avez le temps
mais contre contre les maisons closes
parce que l'argument de dire que c'est
mieux qu'elle soit dans des maisons pas
dans la rue pas dans les bois pas je ne
sais où
ces extraits cesser purement théorique
parce que dans la réalité de ce que sont
les maisons closes c'est des lieux mais
d' abomination et d' esclavage mais
absolue et il ya plein de témoignages de
deux de ses de ces gens qui travaillent
dans les maisons closes qui disent que
c'est la plus grande exploitation de
l'être humain n'est illégal par exemple
à la frontière espagnole qui a encore
légale alors jouvet joachim qui laquelle
a lui cédé poupée donc voilà on silicone
je voulais le dire vous avez quatre
poupées donc c'est ça rien homme qui
arrive bientôt et ça il en chemin ah oui
mais tu oublies maillot l'accord va très
bien mais ça marche bien vous gagnez
bien votre vie j'arrive à manger le way
non c'est vrai je roule pas sur l'or
mais faut être combien de clients par
jour
ah ça je ne peux pas le à peu près on
n'a pas demandé les noms patronne lci et
ouais et savané dans les couloirs des
mille-îles vous allez voir que dans
quelques années ce à quoi il faisait
hier cyril vous enverriez voir arriver
le jour vite que ce qu'on passe avec
l'intelligence artificielle on our à des
femmes qui ressemblent des robots qui
ressemble de plus en plus à des femmes
qui auront une forme d'interactivité
avec le client avec ceux déjà existants
il est 50 mille dollars
ouais c'est pas encore assez rock 50000
dollars et la première a été vendue à un
vrai client à londres il ya quelques
mois la première vraiment allons avec le
sait qu'eric naulleau est en voyage à
londres ya pas longtemps alors bernard
laporte êtes pour les maisons oui je
suis pour les maisons closes pour la
régulation passe effectivement lagathu
un réseau de dire ça ça ne sera pas
peut-être la traite et cetera mais
aujourd'hui ça existe encore d'autres
choses pouvaient déjà régulés ce serait
déjà mieux et parcours de sa suffisance
et pathétique excusez moi je vois qu'il
quoi mon géré comme un client c'est
impossible
ah oui maman et l'enfant pour les vertus
que c'était possible c'est dans la
maison c'est comme un ballon gris
et aucun intérêt à landreville mais sauf
qu'elle elle prévenu la cre a jamais
comme ça s'il on a débattu pendant un
quart d'heure de la main aux fesses oui
avec des degrés d'indignés sévère mais
là on est là mais personne n'oblige à y
aller les gars mais pourquoi vous avez
cahiers on a le droit de jallet pas non
mais certains mais et eric poussé le
bouchon très loin
jean est consterné oui mais ces
quartiers eric je trouve que c'est une
déshumanisation déshumanisation de la
femme qu'on pousse à l'extrême moi je
trouve cela il ya des hommes qui
arrivent mais je trouve ça choquant non
mais je conçois choquant je l'aimais là
c'est une poupée eric quintin non mais
je les remercie ainsi que par un guide
est ce que voilà il n'aime pas du tout
ça mais c'est parce que vous n'avez pas
besoin et penser qu'il ya énormément
d'hommes à paris qui sont en misère
sexuelle la plus profonde et qui arrive
pas avec la santé je sais j'en appelle
un certain maxime guény dernièrement
[Applaudissements]
ne vous en privez renard qu'est ce que
tu disais non je dis bien gentil mais le
festival du jeu je comprends que les
gens qui sont dans la détresse et que
certaines gens qui ne sera même pas
aller voir une vraie pro steicher mais
non je les vois tous les jours à ce
point oui mais on voit il soutient gens
là il n'y a pas de jugement et je vous
avez déjà essayé vous bien sûr non
officielles et les plus longues de sa
liste quoi pour vendre un produit formel
finale
oui c'est vrai que quand on vend des
boissons light et bien non ce n'est pas
de la transit et à part on avait c'est
vrai est-ce qu'il va essayer les autres
non une femme j'ai pas fait ce qu'il
veut et votent la même si vous avez
signé et ne dit rien ben alors on paie
quoi poupée n'est pas très mal
j'aimerais avoir l'avis de medic etc et
vous êtes célibataire et dit non je mari
et moi non il est positif n'est pas
tombé mais dit je suis dit avec les
pancartes est à bord on le voit plus
alors on me dit toi tu irais ce que tu
es pour déjà ce que tu es pour les
maisons cause normalement la réouverture
des maisons closes
c'est compliqué effectivement mais où on
va dire que un peu comme karim et
bernard se retrouve dans la situation
actuelle c'est compliqué de
effectivement de bannir ça donc oui si
c'est une question de régulation
il sent forte que les femmes sont mieux
traités oui je suis pour après voilà je
sais pas comment peuvent pas réellement
là dedans j'y suis jamais allé mais si
tu vis les canards et les jeunes ont
obligé les forêts mais cette voie là
pour moi pour moi le sujet là après sur
ce ce qui se passe là moi ce qui me fait
peur à l'essai fraîchement d'appareils
du japon il a des sondages donnent là
j'attendais donc
si vous nous rejoignez on est en direct
de balance quand on a un garçon qui peut
se réveiller comme ça c'est comme quand
vous êtes chez vous avec votre grand
mère et pappa plat mais en fait c'est
comme s'il avait des électrodes qui peut
dire qui m'inquiète mais effectivement
je manque on voit des reproches sur le
japon on est un peu pour le coup
consterné on se dit fayyad est vraiment
des gens qui ya même des gens qui sont
en couple
voyez partent en week-end avec leurs
coupes et je sais et on est vraiment
dans une situation qui est assez
improbable invraisemblable et se fraie
voilà je suis un peu effrayé par
l'arrivée des choses comme ça me fait un
autre sujet je suis d'accord que c'est
pas alors oui c'est un sujet qui ré
franchement ici autodata non dit la
vérité qui répond à la question du
pardon je voulais dire mon fils est
offert par la fédération française de
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tir et non j'en suis pas là j'irai pas
arrêter vous le savez très bien aller
pourquoi j'irais pas mais en tout cas
merci d'avoir été avec nos lois kim
c'était notre avis tu es mieux vous avez
fêté le convoi si on a fait le tour à
59% contre 41% à l'eau